I'm here today in Manhattan talking to
Dr Jonathan Heit,
who's a professor at Nyu and uh,
I'm here for a bunch of reasons.
Jonathan is an extremely interesting
researcher.
I've been following his work on disgust
and political belief for literally for
decades.
He was one of the first people who
started to do serious research on
disgust,
which is its own emotional system and
therefore very much worth attending to,
um,
but we also have some other interests in
common.
Uh,
Jonathan also started this institute
called the Heterodox Academy,
which is attempting to bring back a
reasonable diversity of views or what he
regards as a reasonable diversity of
views to university faculty on campuses
and discussion.
So,
um,
I first met Jonathan.
It's going to be just about 30 years
ago.
Twenty five years ago.
20 14?
Yeah.
20 site.
The 1994.
Oh,
it was in 1994.
Yeah.
Yeah,
right,
right.
So yeah,
you came to do a job talk at Harvard too
for an assistant professorship position
and I'd been aware of your work on
disgust then and,
and agitated hard for them to hire you
because I thought it was of great
significance,
which turned out to be exactly the case.
So what do you remember about that?
I remember I was so excited to have an
interview at Harvard.
It was my only interview.
I didn't get that job.
I had no job for the following year and
it was a very strange day in which I
didn't feel particularly welcome or
wanted.
And then I had my session with you in
which he was this guy who was had,
he actually got a job at Harvard and he
was studying young,
which is like almost taboo.
And he was talking about dreams and
creativity and so I just.
That was the really bright.
That was the bright memory of the day
was our hour long conversation.
Yeah.
Well I was also really interested at the
time,
man,
now in,
in the biological basis of behavior.
Right.
And so,
and,
and in the,
in the,
in the relationship between fundamental
motivational systems and thought because
obviously our thought is grounded in
fundamental motivational systems and
your work on disgust,
which maybe you can tell the viewers a
little bit about,
was really interesting to me because it
was an emotional system that
hadn't been studied much.
I mean,
you were really one of the pioneers in
the psychological study of discuss what
other way to explain it is that Paul
Ross and my advisor at Penn is the
pioneer in this study of disgust and
he'd studied it as a food related
emotion and he'd written a bit about it
being a moral emotion.
And I was a graduate student at Penn and
I was interested in morality and I was
reading the Bible and I was reading,
um,
uh,
anthropological accounts of different
countries and different cultures.
And at the time morality was all about
reasoning about harm rights and justice.
So Lawrence Kohlberg was the leading
figure in the field and because I was
looking at morality cross cultures,
uh,
and when you look across cultures,
it's not just about fairness and harmon
rights.
It's about menstruation and food taboos
and skin lesions and it's very physical
and I was,
you know,
why?
Why does so many societies,
why is it like the normal default way of
being is to somehow bring the body into
morality?
Why is that?
And so I just happened to be at Penn
where the world's expert in disgust was
and I went to talk to them and that
started one of the best collaborations
of my life.
And what it led to is,
is a broadening of the,
of the moral domain.
Basically there's a sort of a western,
a secular approach you see in western
philosophers.
Either morality is about harm and
utilitarianism and it's minimize harm or
it's about rights and principles,
you know,
manual con and a much better way
psychologically I think about morality
is virtue ethics.
It's just a lot of stuff.
It's just we have just a lot of stuff
that we judge on and this led me
eventually to realize that people on the
left and people on the right care about
different stuff.
Everybody cares about harm and fairness,
but the stuff about keeping boundaries
around the group,
build a wall,
protect the group,
hold the group together,
hate traders.
Um,
you know,
everybody can do that,
but right wing morality builds on these
additional additional foundations of
these additional motions and foundations
so that work on disgust that I was just
beginning to talk about them when we
first met in 1994 lead eventually to
what we now call moral foundations
theory and with my,
with that five or six colleagues that if
you go to your morals.org,
uh,
you can take our tests,
you can learn all about it.
Um,
but it led to the perspective that
ultimately was,
I think the right perspective as the
cultural war was heating up and as left
and right,
we're essentially becoming like
different countries,
different cultures.
So,
so it's not obvious on first
consideration why discussed would be a
moral emotion.
So you know,
most of the work that's done that's
outside of the disgust realm,
I would say is predicated on the
assumption that the reason that
conservatives in particular,
but perhaps people who are more
authoritarian and general draw
boundaries around their territories
because they're afraid of the other,
but that isn't really,
that isn't really how it plays out as
far as I can tell,
because conservatives,
for example,
are less neurotic than treat in the big
five traits sense than liberals,
although it's a,
it's a minor difference,
but the disgust issue seems to be
particularly relevant.
So.
So can you tell us a little bit about
why disgust per se?
Well,
conservatives are a little less
neurotic,
but they also add,
if you do very low level perceptual
experiments,
just like a puff of white noise in the
ear.
People who react more strongly to that
to any sort of very low level threat are
more likely to vote Republican in this
country.
So they're there.
You know,
there are all these interesting
personality differences that lead to
different.
But as for why discussed,
um,
so I'm,
I'm a Durkheimian,
I would say I love the,
uh,
the sociologists,
Emile Durkheim,
and I'm also,
I'm a social psychologist,
so I'm always thinking not about people
as individual utility maximizers,
but people as members of social groups,
people who are totally focused on
belonging in their social groups and
people who have some pro social motives
about keeping the group together,
about doing things that are good for the
group.
So as I tried to argue in my book,
the righteous mind,
yes,
we're selfish.
There's no doubt that we often will do
things to advance our own self interest
at the expense of others.
But we're also really groupish,
which means we'll do all sorts of things
to advance our group at the expense of
others.
Basically,
we're tribal.
We evolved as a tribal species and we're
doing,
we have all this software.
I would say,
oh,
this,
all these predispositions,
these mental predispositions for life
in,
in tribes that are battling other
tribes.
And that's why it comes out so easily.
If you look at the way boys organized
themselves when they get a fraternity,
um,
the hazing rituals,
when you look at the weights,
especially clear in boys the way street
gangs organized themselves,
girls,
tribalism is a little different.
Um,
but I would say this,
and that's why,
again,
I love the [inaudible] and approach of
archetypes or something.
There's just this weird stuff that is
pan human,
even if it comes out slightly
differently around the world,
there really is a human nature and it
comes complete with a whole bunch of
like,
predesigned idea.
So there was a new article,
I think it was published in nature.
I'll try to find the link for it is
about a year old,
um,
that,
that was based on high resolution
imaging of neuronal connections.
It's actually reviewed and Kurt Selles
Kurzweil's book,
how to build a mind.
I think that's the name of it.
Um,
and so it turns out that the Cortex is
made out of these columnar structures
that are pre-organized units of neurons
and they're replicated across the entire
cortex.
Basically the same structure.
And like the,
the,
the older,
let's say connectionist idea was that
neurons that fire together wire
together,
right?
That that's happened.
And of course that's pretty standard
neurology,
but the columns are already prewired.
So it's actually columns that fire
together,
wire together,
but there's,
but there's even more with the high
resolution scanning.
So it turns out that underneath the
columnar structure,
there are these prebuilt highways that
are connected,
connective tissue that are pre,
pre prepared.
So the columns have the option to
connect to the,
to the underlying highway,
and that highway can connect other
columns.
So it's as if in implicit in the brain
organization,
and this is at the cortical level,
say nothing of subcortical organization,
there's already preexistent,
uh,
likelihoods that certain neurons will
fire wire together.
Yeah.
So,
and,
and what else is cool is that this is
actually architecturally quite a
regular.
So they found that the,
these superhighways arranged in lines
and,
and in,
at right angles to one another.
So it's almost like a three dimensional
structure of why your cubes that
underlies the neuronal structure.
So that's a neurological evidence for
the architects.
Cool idea.
Let me just explain to explain to the
viewers here why this isn't just some
like psychological geek conversation.
This is actually really relevant to a
lot of the things that we'll be talking
about that your audience product cares
about because one of the most contested
ideas and the social sciences is the
idea of uniqueness and the idea is what
if something has a need,
then it can't.
It can't vary across societies and if it
varies across societies then it's not an
eight and if gender varies,
if masculinity or femininity vary across
society is not innate,
it's socially constructed,
but that's the wrong understanding of
maintenance.
The definition that I use comes from
Gary.
Marcus was actually neuroscientist here
at Nyu.
He says innate doesn't mean hardwired.
There's almost nothing interesting
that's hardwired.
Innate means structured in advance of
experience,
but that experience can still revise it
and boy does that work for gender,
for almost everything,
for almost everything that we're not a
blank slate about anything.
And something I used to tell my students
at Uva I taught at Uva for 16 years is,
you know,
everything's a social construction,
masculinity,
femininity,
cancer,
the sun,
death,
everything.
There's a social construction for you
won't find a society that doesn't have
thoughts about these things,
but the fact that societies have social
constructions tells us nothing about
whether there's not also an underlying
biological reality and in almost all
cases there.
Well otherwise we wouldn't be able to
communicate,
which is one of Eo Wilson's comments
right?
When Wilson,
this,
the entomologist who studied dance at
Harvard and also wrote a number of books
about sociobiology that got him in
trouble with the radical leftists.
And he said even if we could communicate
with ants,
there'd be nothing to say to each other
because they're fundamental mode of
being in the world is based on
motivations and interests that are so
different from ours.
That there wouldn't be any structure for
communication.
And you can kind of tell that with
regards to the animals that we make
friends with,
right?
We're much more likely to make friends
with animals who has a who have a
fundamental biological and social nature
that's very close to ours like dogs
because we can basically speak their
language even though not completely
a mammo language of love and you know,
I miss you and I want to play with you.
Yeah,
that's right.
exactly.
And that bonding.
Okay,
so back to discuss,
back to discuss.
So I'm.
So the fundamental thing that I learned
from Paul Rosin is to see us as these
amazing omnivores.
This is part of our survival strategy
even more than other other apes.
We are just brilliant omnivores and we
have the Omnivore's dilemma,
which is we've got to be interested in
all kinds of new stuff.
We're not tied to one place.
We can roam onto a whole new continent.
So we were interested in stuff,
but stuff has all kinds of toxins and
microbes.
We have to be careful about that.
And so these motives have to be
intention and this is actually an
interesting way to understand the left,
right?
Difference.
You have to have both motives,
but if so,
imagine two siblings,
one of whom is set more towards trying
new stuff,
seeking out new stuff,
and the other is a little more fearful.
And we're like,
Whoa,
no,
let's,
you know,
let's not try that.
That stayed with what's tried and true.
I mean,
that's progressivism and conservatives
and that's the origins of it.
And if you look at kids' behavior at the
age of two or three,
it does predict how they'll vote much
later.
Not Hugely,
but there is a clear prediction there.
So,
um,
so disgust is part of a regulatory
system about our engagement with the
world and whether we are just sorta out
there and,
you know,
we,
we seek out variety and diversity.
We think diversity is just a great thing
or whether we want a little more order
structure,
predictability.
Conservatives are neater than a
progressive's if you take photos of
their rooms,
um,
you know,
you can actually cleanliness and
organization,
you can predict how they vote,
um,
discussed.
It turns out what's really cool about
disgust in modern politics is if you
look at all the different things that
we're fighting over,
especially in this country,
our culture war is over,
you know,
going back in a few decades,
sex,
drugs,
the flag,
immigration,
all of these things.
Um,
I had to study with my colleagues.
It was led by Seneca Leyva in which we
asked all these cultural war attitudes
of people and we also had their scores
and the discus scale,
but one of the foundations of morality
is sanctity and purity.
And it relates to discuss.
What we found is that if,
you know,
if you know,
um,
uh,
what people's left,
right?
We're,
how they place themselves in the left
rightscale you can pretty much predict
where they fall on most culture war
attitudes except for those that load on
or implicate sanctity,
purity.
So what I mean,
his flag burning.
Okay.
Do you think,
you know,
do you think that people should have the
right to burn the American flag or the
country's flag as an expression,
as a political action?
What do you think people can give some
answer on a one to seven scale and
people on the right thing,
you know,
more like this.
Ain't no people in the left.
Yes.
People who score high on loyalty are
more likely to say no.
People who low lower and say yes,
and that's even taking account of where
they are on the left,
right dimension.
But here's the cool thing,
um,
it's only if you add in the purity or
sanctity thing that you can really
understand what people are doing because
some people see the flag not as just a
piece of cloth.
They see it as having some innate
essence,
some something sacred about it which
must be protected.
And so,
um,
so this is true.
Even they think of it as a unifying
center.
Exactly.
That's right.
So if there's something sacred,
and this is the,
this is the central piece of my work
around politics and morality is the
psychology of sanctity.
If you hold something sacred,
then your team's circles around it.
And it's only those who circle around
with you and sometimes literally circled
around like Muslims at prayer in Mecca.
They literally circle the Kebab circling
is a very primitive,
ancient.
It feels right to circle something,
but even if even if you do it
symbolically or you all bow at the same
time that binds you together,
children do that with their mothers when
they,
when they engage in exploratory
behavior,
right where all they used their mother
as a center of the world and children
differ in the degree to which they'll
move outward from their mother.
So they move out until they,
they,
they trip over their,
their uncertainty threshold.
Neat.
And is it a distance,
like it's a district?
Yeah.
And so,
so the more exploratory kids who are
lower negative emotion will go out
farther before they come back to their
mother.
So the mother is the center and you know
that that would be associated
symbolically with the idea of the center
as a motherland or potentially as a
father like that.
That's right.
That makes sense.
So this way that we're,
we're incredibly symbolic creatures.
We're not just out to make as much money
as we can.
Where's this symbolic and social
creatures and this psychology of
sanctity or purity has become really
important,
not just on the right.
It's always been important for
especially religious conservatives were
beginning to see it even on the campus
left,
and this is why I think we see some of
the odd things we see on campus that the
campus must be kept as a sacred and pure
space.
One of the things that really alarms me
about what's happening on campus last
couple of years is that the older idea
we had that it's a place for contesting
ideas.
It's A.
It's a zone of enormous choice.
People can take what courses they want,
say what they want.
It's kind of a wonderful free for all
with some with norms of respect.
It's now becoming much more of a
religious zone where the perimeter of
the campus is the boundaries and within
its they're almost.
They're blasphemy laws basically,
and I really started noticing this.
When you look at the videos of the
Middlebury,
a protest when Charles Murray spoke at
Middlebury and as,
as everybody knows,
he was shouted down so the students are
chanting and they're chanting in unison
and it seems like a religious revival
meeting and they're swaying and they're
saying they're sacred in a racist,
sexist,
antigay.
Charles Murray go away.
It's like a ritual incantation.
Um,
so that all the space is safe and it's
safe and
not yet.
So far all of this happening is they're
binding together.
They're moving and you know,
synchronous movement and call and
response.
So it's using a lot of tropes from
religion and religious worship.
But here's the cool thing,
when the administrator,
I forget who it is,
comes on to say,
okay,
we have moved,
we're moving the talk.
And then you hear a couple people
screaming out off campus off campus and
he says to another location on campus
and there's like,
oh no,
no,
because you know,
no one had to go to this talk.
So everyone could have just stayed home
and the students did succeed in shutting
down the venues so they could have
declared victory.
But it's not a full victory unless he is
physically off the campus.
We can't have him speaking on because
that defiles
us,
that pollutes us.
We must shut that down.
And that's where I started saying,
wow,
this is like full blown psychology of
religion,
Durkheim,
sanctity,
purity,
blast for me.
Uh,
and that I think,
you know,
that that doesn't describe most students
that,
that describes this sort of the core,
those who who really have their identity
is wrapped up in this movement.
Okay.
So,
so we discussed,
I wanted to,
I wanted to ask you a couple of things
about that.
So,
you know,
the big five research into political
differences basically shows that the
liberals are high in trait,
openness and low in trait
conscientiousness and the conservatives
or the reverse,
but we fragmented conscientiousness into
orderliness and industriousness with the
big five aspects.
Scale and orderliness is strongly
associated with disgust.
So.
So it sounds like Freud.
Yeah,
right,
exactly.
It does sound a lot like Freud but it.
But it also is in accordance with your
observations that conservatives have
neater spaces,
for example.
So,
so now and they're meeting start on
time.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
So.
So then the,
the,
the nexus for political belief seems to
be openness so that that exploratory
tendency that you talked about
exploration of ideas and creativity and
low orderliness and so then I thought,
well why in the world would,
why would the political nexus go across
those dimensions,
which are some relatively uncorrelated
than I thought,
and this is in keeping with your work on
discussed is that it's an issue of
borders,
which of course seems more or less self
evident in the wake of trump's election
when he talked about borders,
but you might say,
and I think this is reasonable,
that the conservative is someone who
wants the borders between categories to
remain intact no matter what level of
analysis.
So it's borders from the highest
resolution level of cognition all the
way up to the actual physical borders
of,
of rooms,
towns,
states,
countries,
all of that.
So the borders should be thicker and the
reason they want that.
Now there was a paper published in Plos
one.
I don't know if you saw it.
It was a couple of years ago,
it was a mind boggling paper,
it should have been front page news as
far as I was concerned and what the
researchers did was between countries
and then within provinces or states
within countries,
they correlated the level of,
um,
of frequency of infectious disease with
authoritarian political beliefs and
found a walloping correlation.
It was like point six.
It was one of the highest by the,
for,
for those of you who don't know,
social scientists never discover
anything that's associated with anything
else at a correlation of point six other
than heritability.
Right?
Other than heritability.
Yes.
And so what they found was that the
higher the prevalence of infectious
disease,
the higher the probability of,
of totalitarian authoritarian political
attitudes,
and then they controlled for governance
because one of the questions was,
was this pop down authoritarianism or
bottom authoritarianism?
And the answer was that it was bottom
up.
Okay.
And so I thought about that in two from
two perspectives simultaneously at the
time.
Okay.
So we identified disgust,
sensitivity with orderliness,
so say a fundamental sub trait.
Then I was reading this book that was
called Hitler's table talk,
and it was a,
it was the recordings of virtually
everything he said at dinner from 1939
to 1942.
Yeah.
So it's a spontaneous utterance,
say and um,
it's full of discussions about Jews and
Gypsies and older people he tormented.
But what's really interesting is all the
language is discussed.
It's not fear.
So,
so Hitler is basic metaphor was that the
Aryan race and country was a pure body
and then it was assaulted by parasites.
Right?
And then I remembered what happened to
the native Americans when the Europeans
showed up and shook hands.
What happened was that 95 percent of
them are dead within 50 years,
right?
Because of smallpox and measles.
And so that,
that border issue that separates
conservatives from liberals,
let's say,
is the conservative say the novel is
potentially contaminated.
It's not so much that it's dangerous.
That's different.
That's fear.
It's contaminated.
And the Liberals say,
hold on a minute.
If you make the borders too thick,
then information can't pass through.
Exactly.
So that's the Omnivore's dilemma right
there.
Right,
right.
And,
and then since we have a biological
architecture on which are cognitive
platforms are erected,
we have the same attitude towards
abstract information,
which would be ideas that we do to
things like food or,
or illness.
Right?
Right.
And so we can think of an invading idea
or a polluting idea or contaminated.
And that's right now I'm a big fan of
George lakoff metaphors.
We live by a that we,
yeah,
we use our bodily or bodily Schema data
to think about abstract things like
politics and like what our policies
should be about borders and immigration.
Uh,
there's a Canadian psychologist,
mark shaller.
He and his colleagues have developed
what they call an account over these,
the behavioral immune system,
right?
That we don't just try to,
you know,
microbes killed probably many more of
our ancestors then did lions and tigers
and bears and so whoever can keep
themselves and their children from being
exposed to fatal illnesses,
winds the evolutionary game.
And so a lot of that is judging
carefully about people.
Is he dangerous,
dangerous.
And that's both for sexuality,
for contact,
for all kinds of association.
Um,
so yeah,
and a lot of ways our emotions and our
bodily interactions structure,
how we think and feel about about
social.
Well even with the black death in
Europe,
I mean,
so the black death occurred in Europe
when the Europeans started to move
around the world and they brought back
rats that were infected.
Exactly.
So,
so what you saw there was both of those
forces at work at the same time.
So the European expansion produced a
tremendous interchange of ideas from all
around the world.
That's globalization,
but it wiped out somewhere between 30
and 60 percent of the population at the
same time.
So wouldn't it be good if in every
society,
every organization.
And we had some people who specialized
in,
uh,
a specialized in saying,
hey,
what are the opportunities?
And then we had other people who
specialize in saying,
well,
but what are the risks?
And it just so happens that a lot of
people have trouble doing all that in
themselves.
When we have systems that are well
constituted with people who have
different personalities and different
motives and goals,
we actually can get better at.
We can have a discussion between them.
Yeah,
well that's exactly why that is for that
precise reason that,
that I've been so interested in free
speech as a,
as a,
as a value because or even on the
economic front,
it's pretty obvious if you look at
things economically that the
entrepreneur types who start businesses
are lumped in with the liberal creative
types.
We've done a lot of work on the
prediction of entrepreneurial behavior
on the ability and his openness.
That's the big predictor.
It's not the only one.
It's openness and ICU fundamentally,
but for managerial and administrative
expertise,
it's,
oh,
it's Iq and conscientiousness.
So the liberal start businesses,
but they can't run them because they're
there.
Their interests flipped and they don't
have the organizational ability and the
conservatives can run them,
but they can't continue to transform and
expand them.
Yeah.
10 and Yang.
Yin and Yang.
Yep.
So,
so one more thing about what happened in
Nazi Germany that that's very relevant
and interesting because it's,
it's useful to get these motives right.
You know,
first of all,
if,
if something disgusts you,
if something,
if you're afraid of something then you
run away from it or you free,
but if something disgusts you,
you try to burn it or dig or kill it.
Right.
You try to get rid of or expel it.
That's,
that's right though.
You want to get it away and destroy it.
So when Hitler came to power,
he putting a bunch of public health
schemes,
like a,
he had vans that went around and screen
people for tuberculosis and then he went
on a factory,
cleanliness,
a campaign.
So the factories were supposed to be
tidy it up and he,
he washed,
he made about four times a day by the
way.
It's also a great worship or of
willpower,
which is associated with orderliness and
seems maybe to be associated with
disgust sensitivity in some way that
isn't yet understood.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't,
I don't understand that connection
either.
So they,
he convinced factory owners in Germany
to get rid of the rats and the mice and
the mice and the and the insects in the
factories and also to clean them up and
beautify them.
But the gas they use to clean up the
factories was like lawn a and it was the
variation of that gas cycle on b that
was then used in.
Yeah.
So you could see this ramping up based.
So it was.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So it was public health,
then it was social cleanliness,
then he went into the asylums and
cleaned them up and so it was just this
expansion of who was contaminated and
who was impure.
And I think also his fascination with
fire and his use of fire symbolism was
also associated with that.
Would that appeal to purification?
Because the whole idea of purification
by fire
is a very ancient idea.
So.
Okay.
So,
so how did your work on discuss change
the way that you looked at things
fundamentally mean you gave some
indication of that already,
but what else has changed?
Um,
so since I was coming out of a,
of a psychological literature that was
very focused on,
on sort of secular,
secular ethics about justice and
fairness,
and then I began studying disgust and
looking at the broader moral domain.
They're almost all societies have.
That then also led me to think about,
well,
okay,
if disgust is a reaction to things that
seem to be degrading.
So an interesting element of discusses
this notion of degradation that there
are always these vertical metaphors.
I'm a image discuss,
brings us down and discussed.
So a lot of some religious practice in
Judaism and Islam and Hinduism is about
preparing your body to approach God and
uh,
purification.
And so that led me to think,
well,
if there's an emotion which is about
seeing our lower base or animal
biological nature,
is there an opposite?
Emotion is an emotion of that.
We feel when we see some manifestation
of a higher nobler nature.
And I was just beginning to think this
one.
I moved to Uva.
I got my first job at University of
Virginia in 1995 and I read a stat of
Thomas Jefferson's letters.
And in one letter he describes,
he describes the feelings you get from
reading great fiction,
he advises a cousin of his that he
should buy fiction for his library,
not just serious works of law and
philosophy.
And he described,
he says,
doesn't,
he describes the feeling of,
of,
uh,
of uh,
having your sentence be elevated,
does it not dilate your breast or give
you an open feeling in your chest when
you see these acts of beauty and
kindness and gratitude?
I thought,
wow,
that's exactly it.
Um,
and so because I've been studying
disgust,
I then started studying its opposite
which I and some others called moral
elevation.
So this is kind of vertical metaphor of
elevation and degradation and snaps onto
the body to,
with regards to.
That's right.
High low,
a clean,
dirty in.
Yeah,
it's a beautiful pairing.
And so having this language of elevation
and discussed just really has helped me
see a lot of things.
I just,
I just see a lot of things happening.
It allows me to like even,
you know,
manipulate like have been applying for a
grant proposal.
Like I can get very good at like having
an elevating ending,
you know,
to,
um,
uh,
to end with a note of uplift.
And so it just brought,
it just broadened my thinking about
morality.
And this was around 1995.
And so again,
it just prepared me is that I'm a and
I'd already been to India by that point.
I spent three months doing research in a
Rissa in eastern India.
Um,
so it just broadened my thinking and
that's what allowed me finally to
understand conservatives because I had
always been on the left.
I hated Ronald Reagan.
Um,
I thought Republicans were stupid and
evil and it was only when I had gone to
India and really tried to understand a
traditional religious hierarchical
gender stratified society.
Tried to understand it in their terms.
They didn't try to just bring in my own,
my own western left,
you know,
left leaning perspectives,
um,
that I was.
And this was all under the guidance of
Richard Schwayder,
my postdoc supervisor at the University
of Chicago where did a postdoc.
It was only then that I was able to sort
of get inside their minds and their
moral system and see that there were
alternative moral worlds.
They each had their own logic and that
was the metaphor I came to it.
You know,
the time,
you know,
the matrix movies were very popular.
So the metaphor,
the Matrix as a consensual hallucination
made a lot of sense.
It's where I can up with the idea of
just speaking about moral matrices,
whichever different matrices that are
grounded in biology,
biology in the sense that it gives us
the potential.
It's like the building blocks of this
matrix can't be just anything that
comes,
it comes from our experiences are
embodied experiences and again,
George Lakoff is the,
is the master of,
of,
of that thinking.
And so it was only then that I was able
to now listen to conservative talk radio
and Christian religious radio and see,
rather than just saying,
oh,
that was stupid terrible.
People say like,
Oh wow.
Yeah,
I can see that they're striving for
certain version.
Right.
So you started to understand their
metaphorical language essentially.
That's right.
And that was like kind of like my,
you know,
I know a great awakening or scales
falling from my eyes,
but you know,
since.
But it took a few more.
It took a number of,
a lot more years.
But eventually I kind of just pulled out
the implants from my eyes and I stopped
seeing everything through a partisan
lens and I'm not on any side now.
I'm just trying to understand what the
hell is.
Well,
it's really useful.
It's really useful to understand that
there are actual reasons why people see
the world differently and that you can't
just easily say that one is right and
the other is wrong because the liberals
are correct when it comes to borders.
That if you thicken them too much and
diminish the information flow,
you risk making the society so static
that any radical environmental
transformation will sink it.
It's the case,
but the conservatives are right in that
you pay a big price with regards to
newcomers and new information with
regards to risk to exposure to
contaminating while to contamination
period,
but also to contaminating ideas.
And so then I've always thought,
you know,
the environment itself moves back and
forth like a snake in some sense,
and what we're trying to do is stay on
the center of its back and the only way
we can do that is by people,
by having people pull to the right and
say,
be careful.
And people pulled to the left and say,
well,
yeah,
but be open with that dialogue and the,
the exchange of information that,
that dialogue allows.
We can maybe specify the center of that
moving target and stay and stay well and
stay on the back,
let's say.
Ah,
okay.
So that's a really complicated metaphor
with the snake,
but I think it's a perfect way in to
what's going on on campus.
And two,
why viewpoint diversity is so important
because that's,
I agree exactly with what you just said.
And so what I,
the view that I've come to in studying
moral psychology is that we have,
is that humans are ultra social apes.
Um,
we,
we evolved to live in these small groups
that are fighting with each other.
Uh,
we evolved to have these low level
animistic religions.
That's our steady state,
that's the way we were for at least
100,000
years,
are much more closer to a million in
some form.
Um,
so that's sort of our design.
That's what we're designed for in a
sense.
Um,
and in that sense where as individuals
really kind of stupid tribal creatures
designed to do post hoc reasoning,
um,
but if you put us together in the right
way with the right checks,
with the right,
the right systems,
um,
the whole can be vastly smarter than the
components that go into it,
which is true of the brain,
to the brain is composed of neurons.
Each neuron is kind of stupid little
switch,
but you put them together in the right
way and you get something really
brilliant and at the same way,
um,
I don't know all the history here,
but my understanding is that science
begins or the culture of science,
the scientific revolution begins in
Europe in the 17th century.
As you begin getting,
you get the printing press so people can
share their ideas,
but you get communities of people who
are challenging each other's ideas.
And that's what makes it so brilliant is
that is that people have to do their
best.
We're really bad at this confirming our
own ideas.
It's very hard to make it very hard to
do that.
But you put your ideas out there and
then everyone else is motivated to
challenge them.
And so if you put us together in the
right way,
the truth comes out.
And so adversarial systems of law
journalists know this.
They have to listen to both sides.
Scientists know this.
Social scientists should know this.
Okay?
What happened?
Well,
I'm,
the academy has,
has always leaned left in the 20th
century,
but leaning isn't a problem.
So people think,
oh,
viewpoint diversity we need,
we need everybody.
We need Nazis.
We need every,
the,
no,
we don't need everybody.
What we need is no orthodoxy.
That's what's fatal orthodoxy.
So if you have a,
if you have to feel it,
like sociology or social psychology in
which it's two or three to one left to
right,
that's totally fine with me.
That's totally fine.
Uh,
because if someone makes some claim
that's just like ideologically blind,
someone will say,
uh,
you know,
common sense,
other evidence that you've missed and
then the system works.
But what I learned when I started down
this road in 2011,
I gave a talk at the big conference with
social psychologists.
I gave a talk about this problem that
we're losing our diversity,
that I could only find one conservative
in the entire field and I gave a talk on
this.
Um,
and um,
um,
and so what I've learned since then is
that the ratio in psychology was between
two to one in Florida.
One left,
right?
All the way up to the early nineties.
We've gathered together all the studies
we could find.
So all the up to the early nineties,
it's only three or four to one left to
right,
which would be okay,
but between 1995 or four and 2010,
it goes to a 14 to one.
Do you have any idea why and why that
time?
Yes.
So,
um,
so you get the same story whether you
look at Republican,
Democrat ratios or liberal conservative
there,
they tell the same story.
So the,
two of the big things going on there are
one is that the greatest generation
which had a lot of Republicans,
um,
so a lot of men go off to World War Two,
they on there,
on the Gi bill,
they entered the academy in the 19
fifties.
A lot of them are conservative or
Republican and so you have a lot of
them,
but in the sixties and seventies,
one of the main reasons to go to Grad
school and the social sciences is either
a,
to stay in school to escape the Vietnam
war draft or be to fight for social
justice and against racism.
So in sociology and psychology in
particular in political science,
maybe,
I'm not sure,
you get a huge influx of left leaning
people who are there to pursue social
justice.
So you know,
the motives are fine and if it was
balanced to be totally fine,
but as you get these young junior people
on the left come in in the seventies and
eighties and then you get the older
people that are more politically
bounced,
retiring of the eighties and nineties by
the time you get to the late nineties,
it's all baby boomers.
And so do you get a,
you get a positive feedback loop
developing their,
like you said,
it's like three to one.
It's okay,
but maybe when it hits four to one,
it goes to like 20 to one,
then you stay.
Exactly.
So then,
so then you start getting hostile
climate.
So I wrote a review paper on this with
a,
with Joe Duarte and Phil tetlock and
lead Justin Jarrett,
Crawford.
Um,
um,
and um,
and we,
uh,
we reviewed everything that we could
find and we concluded that most of
what's going on is self selection.
That is people on the left are more open
to experience.
They're always going to get self
selection.
But then there's really good evidence
that there's also hostile climate.
I mean,
it's undeniable now that if you are not
on the left in a Grad program,
there's just constant little subtle or
not so subtle reminders that you don't
belong.
And look in the academy,
we're all about saying,
Hey,
if there are subtle hints here and
there,
you can't succeed,
right?
I mean,
that's what we do for a living is we say
that little things will stop people.
Um,
well,
little things are put in the way of
anyone who doesn't fit politically.
Uh,
and so you do get hostile climate.
You do get over discrimination.
There's evidence of that.
And then there is also,
it is part of the story here that what
it means to be a conservative in the
nineties and especially to thousands has
changed.
So it is true that you know,
that,
that the,
the conservative,
we're not in any way anti science,
um,
until much more recent times.
Now actually all sides are anti science
fact,
different sciences.
But I'm in America,
they're the right wing.
The Republican Party has,
it's controversial,
but I do believe that the polarization
starts with the right moving further
out.
So what it means to be conservative to
the anti anti evolutionary,
which is actually what's happening on
the left now to exactly.
That's so as this modern like talked to
Brent Weinstein the other day and you
know,
he,
one of his claims is that evolutionary
biology has something in it to offend
everyone.
So it's a,
it's a science that's very likely to be
targeted by extremist.
You also brought up something that
actually touches on the ICT on the
difficult problem of how it is that you
might define someone whose ideologically
possessed,
let's say,
or ideologically rigid because the idea
was that you can make a valid case for
the utility of free information flow
and,
and the free flow of people that would
go along with that and you could make a
good case for the danger of that.
And so the idea might be that if you're
only making a case for the danger of
that,
then you're tilted too far to the right.
And if you're only making a case for the
utility of that,
then you're tilted too far to the left.
Exactly.
That's right.
And so we can look at immigration as a
nice example.
There was a recent essay in the
Atlantic,
I think it was by Peter Beinart where
he,
um,
he reviews,
he had started with a lot of quotes that
are pretty nuanced positions about
immigration from Barack Obama,
Paul Krugman and a bunch of other people
on the left who used to be able to say,
on the one hand,
you know,
compassion,
economic,
on the other hand,
you know,
we have to have a legal process and
there's a threat to low wage workers.
So people on the left,
you still have to talk about immigration
and talk about the pros and cons,
the pluses and minuses.
But beinart shows how in the last four
or five years you can't,
if you so much as suggest that will,
maybe immigration is a net good,
but it might have some deleterious
effects on certain classes of,
of low wage American workers.
You could get in big trouble,
right?
Because that's instantly prejudicial
because immigration has become a sacred
topic.
So this is the key thing that I want
everyone to keep in mind.
We are fundamentally religious
creatures.
Were built for religion and it's a great
achievement to create a scientific
establishment and an academic
establishment that keeps that way of
thinking out.
Scientific thinking is not natural
thinking.
Religious thinking is natural thinking
and what's happening to us in the last
few years especially is a flooding in of
religious thinking,
and so let's get a bunch of social
scientists talk about immigration.
What are they going to do?
Look at the data,
way up.
The pluses and minuses.
No,
they're going to.
Many of them feel they're on a team and
that team is fighting the right.
The right is anti-immigrant.
It includes racist elements,
therefore that justifies us in being
pro.
Immigration and social sciences are
always.
There's always ambiguity.
There's always conflicting studies,
multiple causal factors.
Is that always in the social science
study?
That's right.
So buying art's point was that the left
used to be able to think straight about
immigration.
Clearly it had a generally pro
immigration,
but it used to be able to think
straight,
but in the last few years a religious
orthodox mindset has overtaken it.
Okay.
So we might as well also pointed out
that it's a primordial religious
mindset,
right?
Because I mean there are,
yeah,
definitely Christian or Jewish,
I mean ancient tribal,
small scale,
lots of gods.
Right,
right.
Well,
so then one of the things that you might
suggest is that when you throw out a
sophisticated religious structure,
an unsophisticated religious structure
comes in to fill the gap.
I do.
So that's true.
That's definitely worth thinking about.
So that's right.
The thing to the right with religions,
we have to clarify a fundamentalism is
the problem,
not religion.
And so if you close tribalism,
that's right.
If you get a fundamentalist,
you know,
I'm happy to stay.
And if you have people applying to a
Grad program in psychology and I find
out that they're Christian,
that's fine.
There's no problem.
But if they're fundamentalist Christian,
I would think,
well let's say let's say it's not
psychologists,
suppose it's,
you know,
geology.
So someone applies to a geology program,
there are fundamentalist young earth
creationist.
Are you gonna admit them?
No,
I don't think you should.
They're not able to do the right kind of
thinking based on what we know to be the
case.
They're there.
They're not in the scientific paradigm,
not in the Santa that's right.
So,
so if we wouldn't admit a fundamentalist
Christian to a geology program,
why would we admit someone who is just
as fundamentalist about certain moral
and political issues into a sociology
program or into a psychology program if
they come in knowing what the right
answer is committed to that right
answer.
Likely to get angry at anyone who
contravenes that right answer.
Um,
and,
and showing signs of close mindedness.
I don't think they belong in a grab the.
I guess the question is how in the world
do you set up mechanisms to ensure that
you're not swamped by fundamentalists of
any sort?
So those are people who are reducing
everything to a single cause.
It's something like that.
How can you implement a structure that
protects the organization against that
without the structure itself becoming
totalitarian?
Because these things,
these things spin out of control so
fast.
But so what we have to realize in the
academy is that we face,
I think we face an existential crisis.
Um,
we rely in enormous amount on public
goodwill.
We get enormous tax subsidies,
a direct research support,
and recent polling shows that while
Democrats have always had a higher
opinion of the universities and
Republicans until two years ago,
everybody thought universities are a
good thing.
They make life better.
So Americans have been very supportive
of higher education.
There have been rising grapes on the
right,
but it's only between 2015 and 2017 that
now republicans go from saying mostly
universities are good things in two
years.
They go way down and say universities
are bad things.
They're making things worse.
Now,
how is this news greeted pundits on the
Left Rsa?
Oh,
those republicans are so anti science.
Look how ignorant they are.
They now hate universities.
Come on.
Anybody who's been watching the news,
anybody who's seen the mobs to shout
downs,
the illiberal behavior.
You know,
the metaphor I use is like,
you know,
Americans on the right and left are
really supportive of the military.
We have a,
it's one of the few institutions that we
still hold in highest team on both
sides,
and so the Republicans more than
Democrats.
So suppose you had Gallup poll and I,
uh,
showing Republicans liked the military
more than Democrats,
but both really like it.
Then suddenly in 2015 we started seeing
video from all over military bases,
the military academies in which the,
the military leaders are overtly right
wing.
They're there,
they're saying terrible things about
leftists and progressives and the
midshipmen and cadets,
and everybody is mobbing the occasional
liberal and they're behaving in a really
despicable,
scary and intimidating way.
What do you think the left would now
think about the military?
Obviously support for the military would
plummet and that's what's happening in
America with universities.
We are losing the support of half the
country.
This is unsustainable,
especially in red states where they
control the purse strings.
So I think we have a major crisis.
I think we've got to go into crisis mode
and we've got to clean up our act.
So just as we're doing in psychology
with replication project W,
we recognize that our methods weren't
good enough and we're doing a crash
course,
a thanks to Brian Nosek and others,
the open science project.
We're really trying to improve our game.
Thank God we need to.
I think we have to do the exact same
thing about partisanship,
um,
and our,
our duties.
Okay.
So let's talk about Heterodox Academy
because you set that up,
this organization that you should tell
everybody about in,
in precisely to deal with this issue.
And so I'd like,
I'd like to know about how it's growing,
what it's doing,
what your aims are,
all of that.
Yeah.
So I gave this talk in 2011 laying out
the fact that we have no more
conservatives and social psychology and
why this makes it hard for us to find
truth.
And uh,
in the months after that,
a few social psychologists resonated
with the message.
They said,
wow,
I think that,
I think you're right.
I have some data on this.
So the five of us,
six of us wrote this paper,
came out in behavioral and brain
sciences.
I'm Charlotte a stern,
I'm sorry,
what's the sixth one that I forgot to
add in before?
Um,
we got this paper published and behavior
and brain sciences.
It came out,
it was sort of online in 2014,
but it came out for good in the summer
of Twenty 15,
which coincidentally was the same summer
that my article came out with Greg
Glucagon off of the coddling of the
American mind.
That was about things going on with
undergrads.
But our concern was entirely faculty.
It was just the nature of the academic
community,
the research community.
So we got these two things going on
summer of Twenty 15.
Um,
and then that summer I hear from Nick
Rosenkranz,
a law professor who says we have the
same problem in law,
lost worse in law.
Well,
it really bad and Canada law.
Okay.
Because,
and as he points out,
we're training all these students,
they never meet a conservative.
Then they have to go argue cases in
front of judges,
half of whom were appointed by
Republicans.
They have no idea what a conservative
thinks.
This is malpractice.
We've got to train.
So say,
and I hear from a sociologist,
Chris Martin,
same thing in sociology,
so the three of us said,
hey,
you know,
this is a big problem for the whole
account.
Have you looked at faculties of
education?
Oh my God,
those are the worst by worst,
I don't know the numbers,
but in terms of the vindictiveness that
the increased the pressure put on any
nonconforming opinion.
My impression,
I don't have data,
but my impression from the letters I get
is that
education schools and social work
schools are the worst.
That's exactly in keeping with my.
My understanding as well.
It's hard to tell which of those two or
worst I would say it's the faculties of
education because they have a direct
pipeline to kids,
but in terms of their effect,
farmer pernicious.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
But,
but equally equally worked let's say,
but but more pernicious and the things
that are happening in the Canadian
education system as a consequence of
that or so reprehensible,
which we'll get to that because it's
happening here too with these ideas
filtered down to high school.
I've been so focused on college,
now we're discovering the problem is
actually baked in.
The liberal attitudes are often baked in
by the time,
right?
Yes.
And purposefully,
like in,
in Canada,
increasingly the,
the radical leftists have control over
curriculum development and they're
starting to develop social justice
curriculum,
which is what they call them for,
for kindergarten kids.
So let's finish up the headrest academy
then we'll get back to the earlier
grades.
So,
uh,
so originally three of us decided to put
up a website.
I invited all the other authors from
the,
the bbs paper.
We invited a few other people working on
this.
And so for the first year we had this
project,
it was called Heterodoxacademy.org.
Uh,
we put the site up on about September
10th,
I think it was a 2015 and it was just a
community of researchers who are
studying the problem of the lack of
viewpoint diversity.
Well,
five days later the protest start at
Missouri.
So these are racially motivated protest
or protest about racial insensitivity in
racial problems at Missouri.
Um,
and at first it seemed like this is just
a Missouri prompt,
but coming in the wake of course,
of of Ferguson and all the videos we saw
of,
of unarmed black men being killed by
police,
the,
a lot of these concerns spread to other
universities.
The protests aren't just about race,
but it was that fall of 2015,
especially the Yale protest when the
president of Yale validates their
narrative that Yale's are racist place.
We have to reform Yale and then it
spreads nationally and now suddenly this
is not just a faculty issue anymore.
So even though it Heterodox Academy,
we're mostly focused on the faculty were
now seeing it's a complex ecosystem with
all kinds of forces acting on
universities so that between 2015 and
2017,
the danger of speaking honestly about
what you think about an academic or
intellectual proposition has
skyrocketed.
The risk of being mobbed,
ostracized,
formally investigated by title nine
people for each title.
Nine people here,
we're sitting here at Nyu,
go to any bathroom,
I'll,
I'll show you on this floor.
Go to any bathroom.
There's a sign telling students exactly
what number to call to report you or me
if we say something that is,
that someone takes to be a bias.
Oh,
so you have bias.
You have bias investigation teams here.
That's right.
See,
we haven't got to that point at that
particular point in Canada yet.
So I think we're farther ahead down that
path in some ways but not quite as far
and others.
So yeah,
that's really,
that's really unbelievable.
So things are changing very,
very fast.
It's not at all schools.
Uh,
but then again,
things are changing so fast.
We don't really know.
We don't have good data on what's going
on.
What I can tell you though is that a,
at Heterodoxacademy when we started out
in 2015,
there was a lot of suspicion.
A lot of people on the left were afraid
like,
oh,
is this some right wing group?
Now very few of us are actually on the
right.
Um,
but because we end up mostly speaking up
for Libertarians and conservatives who
are attacked or silenced,
you know,
people will think,
oh,
we must be right wing,
but we're not.
I mean,
I'm,
I've never voted for a Republican in my
life,
I've never given money to Republican
campaign.
Um,
I'm now increasingly calling myself a
liberal now that we see illiberalism
flourishing.
Um,
but so when we started out,
there was a lot of suspicion of us from
many professors,
but now that it's clear that the
problems,
these are not just a few anecdotes.
This is the new normal,
um,
and it's not just in the university.
So as you pointed out,
that's right.
It's reading,
reading,
and it's not just in the U.
S it's spread.
When in Twenty 15,
I thought it was uniquely American
problem.
Yes,
it's in Canada and the UK and Australia
and New Zealand.
That's right.
It is a uniquely anglosphere problem.
This is really interesting.
It's not on the continent very much at
all.
What about in the Nordic countries?
No,
I mean they have.
So political correctness,
you have lots of places.
The unique thing that identifies this
new culture is linking the political
correctness with the sense of fragility.
And this is something America's
pioneered the idea that,
um,
so the in Britain,
they've always had,
um,
uh,
no platforming they call it.
So if there's an end,
there was an effort,
British National Party,
it's actual fascist party,
you know.
So if a,
if a BNP is going to speak on campus,
mob him,
you shut it down.
No,
don't give him a platform.
So,
you know,
you've had passionate politics certainly
since the sixties.
So that's not new and that's everywhere.
Um,
what's new is the American idea that if
someone says something and it could be a
sincerely expressed idea,
not a racist rant,
just like,
well,
I don't know.
I think that maybe hormones do affect
gender behavior.
Can you say that?
Well,
what if someone takes that as,
as somehow essentially using gender and
then saying that women are inferior or
whatever,
if they don't.
Well happened to James Demora for.
Exactly.
So,
um,
so that's what's new is the idea that if
someone says something that someone,
a member of a protected or marginalized
group is offended by,
that person is harmed.
If that person has harmed,
we must protect that person and more
ominously just in the last year or two.
It's not just that they're harming their
suffering,
it's that this was violating his right
violence.
Well,
that's part of the postmodern narrative.
That and distributes whole thing to pass
is so dangerous.
The crossing the line into,
into violence.
It just occurred to me just like
yesterday,
I was thinking about this.
Wait,
the state is supposed to have a monopoly
on violence,
right?
But if speech,
especially his speech and her speech and
the people,
the speech of those people in that
academic movement or on the and that,
if their speech is violence,
well the state is supposed to have a
monopoly on their speech then.
And um,
and if it's violence,
well then we have a right to use
violence back.
The state doesn't have a monopoly on
violence because our violence is,
you know,
morally motivated.
So just the Orwellian and authoritarian
implications of this move.
Once you say that speech is violence,
you're unlocking your opening Pandora's
box.
I mean your,
your five steps down the road to hell.
And I'd say we're about seven steps down
the road too,
so.
Okay.
You.
So you're,
you're that concerned about it.
Okay.
So now tell me how many,
how many members are,
if you don't have to discuss any of this
obviously,
but how many members of Heterodox
Academy are there now?
We have 1300 members,
so once we opened up.
So originally it was just for
researchers who were studying this
problem,
but we had lots of people wanting to
join and so we said,
well,
okay,
why not?
And so we just said,
right,
if as long as you're a professor that
is,
you have a phd,
you're living more or less the life of a
professor,
you have a university affiliation.
So we now take adjuncts.
If they have a phd,
we take postdocs.
Basically if you're in the guild,
if you're living the life of a professor
and you're concerned about the rise of
intimidation,
frankly,
if you're concerned that our wonderful
institution I love,
I love being a professor,
I love the academy and I feel like it's
not just losing public respect,
it's losing its ability to function.
It's losing its ability to teach and do
research on politicized topics,
so there were more politicized topics
all the time.
That's.
That's right,
and there are a few in the natural
sciences,
not many,
but there are some in the natural
sciences as well.
Anyway,
my point is we're now growing very
rapidly and something I'm very excited
by is since we started having more
violence on campus with beginning with
birth and Middlebury,
we're seeing a pervasive sense among
people on the left that there really is
this problem here that something has to
be done and so we are finding much more
acceptance now.
I'm from professors on the left,
so I like to think about there's the
liberal left,
which is the great majority,
and there's the illiberal left.
We did a factor analysis of politically
correct beliefs and found exactly that
and that the and that the illiberal left
was also high in orderliness.
That's interesting.
Just the authoritarian.
Exactly.
Predisposition and also kind of markedly
declined was also characterized by a
market,
lack of verbal intelligence.
Oh,
that's point four.
Well that.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
Because one of the simplest formulation
I've heard really great formulation from
Mark Lilla,
so mark Lilla wrote this fantastic op
Ed,
the New York Times week after trump was
elected saying identity politics is a
really foolish thing to do.
It pushes lots of people over to trump's
side.
You have identity politics is part of
the problem.
Well,
he writes this off Ed and one of his
fellow professors at Columbia,
I forget how she does it,
but she basically says something about
the,
you know,
the mask with eye holes,
falls from his face,
like,
you know,
he's a Ku Klux Klan member or something
like that.
And so Lilla Lilla who isn't the
humanities,
he's an intellectual historian.
Lilla has this simple formulation.
He says that's a slur,
not an argument.
And once they had that simple
formulation,
I realized,
wow,
that's almost all the pushback I've ever
gotten.
It's somehow,
you know,
oh,
you're winking at Nazis or your comfort
to me over and over.
I was just,
my neighborhood was just posters with
all that,
the intimidation.
So,
so this is really key.
We're supposed to be all about,
you can say anything you want,
you can make any argument you want,
if you can support it,
if you can back it with reasons.
This is critical thinking and this is
what we're supposed to train our
students to do.
Well,
and not only that you can say anything,
but you can say it.
There's a boundary on that,
which especially if you're a scientist,
less so in the humanities,
but if you're a scientist,
the things you say have to be vetted by
people who are going to be critical of
them.
Right.
So,
so not only,
not only there's accountability built
into it.
That's right.
So I didn't mean to say you can say
whatever you want rant.
I mean you can put forth any idea you
want,
if you can back it up.
What we're seeing with anything
politicize is it's not about backing it
up.
Students are learning rhetorical
techniques to link their enemies to
something racist,
sexist,
contemptible sometimes.
And those are the things that are not
only worthy of being destroyed,
but that you have a moral duty to
destroy.
Exactly.
So that's right.
So it's almost like the immune system,
how exactly works,
but there's some cell that tags Acel as
enemy enemy and once that tag is put on
the cell that attract other effort that
what kind of sell to mob it and so we
should look into this,
this metaphor of the immune system,
because once they know,
once you're labeled as a racist,
the students don't have to read you that
it doesn't matter what you actually say.
You will now be attached to that.
Once you're labeled that way,
if someone defends you,
the label is contagious.
Dynamic.
That's how we know we're in this super
religious territory of witch hunts that
if you stand up for someone,
you are tagged and then you will be
mobbed.
And that's why there's so much that.
And that's why there's so much cowardice
on campus among both students and
faculty.
People are afraid to stand up even if
the majority think that what's going on
is nuts or is unfair.
They're afraid to stand up and that's in
part due to social media because it's
just.
I mean,
students today had been raised with
various platforms that make it easy for
people to join in attacks,
someone they look at who liked what.
So if in that article we just saw on
read a,
there was a bit of a counterrevolution
and read the students had to get
together somehow and decide should I
like that post?
How about if we all liked it at the same
time,
then we'll get in less trouble.
Okay.
So to what degree.
So let's talk about the aims of the
Heterodox Academy.
So you brought people together who are
in principle interested in a diversity
of opinions and but,
but in what manner is that going to be
utilized to,
to,
I don't want to use the word combat but
but to deal with this emergent problem
of ideological rigidity in the
universities.
So two useful concepts here.
One is the emperor's new clothes.
Um,
we all know that story.
Even if most people,
even if everybody sees this is nuts,
the emperor's walking around with no
clothes,
they're afraid to say it until one
person says it.
So,
and this is also the ash experiment,
everybody says that that line is the
same as that line.
It's obviously not true.
If one person says the truth,
then nobody conforms after that.
So the mere presence of a group of
people who say,
you know what,
we actually need a diversity of opinions
and the fact that on our site we'll
publish things.
So sometimes when professors are mob,
like when Bret Weinstein was mobbed,
you know,
so I wrote an essay that stood up for
him.
Uh,
we've done that for some of them.
It's happening so fast,
I can't keep up,
I can't,
I've got books to write and I,
you know,
every week there's some new member who's
getting mobbed.
And so we're going to develop a team of
people who will write.
But just knowing that there are people
who will stand up for you.
Um,
knowing that there are people who will
say,
wait a second,
um,
you know,
this is not what we do in the academy.
So that's one things we just stand up
for each other too,
is we develop products that we think can
basically fix the situation.
So one of our products is called the
campus expression survey.
It's a survey designed to actually
measure who was afraid of speaking up
about what topics and why,
what are they afraid of?
And it turns out everyone's afraid of
the students more than the faculty.
Uh,
they're afraid of mostly to talk about
race.
What about the administrators?
Everyone's afraid of the students.
They're afraid of the students.
So I don't have,
we have not sorted them.
I've only surveyed students,
I don't know,
but from what we hear people are afraid
of,
of the students,
um,
hauling in its own manner.
Like was that failure of leadership?
That's for sure.
They let those kids come into the
classroom,
the actual classroom and disrupt a class
on an ongoing basis.
I mean,
yes,
and I couldn't understand that exactly.
I mean,
my response to that would be first I
would tell them to leave.
Second,
I would call campus security.
Third,
if something wasn't done about it,
I just wouldn't teach the class.
So I don't understand like it,
it seems to me that it's also up to
individual professors to draw a line,
which is that if you're being
intimidated dated by students,
why do you,
why do you show up and teach the class?
I don't understand that.
Yeah.
So again,
people are afraid to stand up if it
means that people will call you a racist
cabot garden.
I mean,
it's weird in that situation though
because it's carried to enroll her to go
to your class,
you know,
and,
and there's a much more proximal
threats.
That's what I mean.
That's what I'm most alarming
by is the rise of intimidation.
Intimidation is now a factor in many
aspects of academic life and that's just
terrible.
That's completely incompatible with,
with what we do and who we are.
Well,
it's especially,
it's especially appalling given that
whatever happens in the university
campuses,
one of the Christians I'd faced in
Canada as well,
why should we care about what's
happening in the,
in the Ivy Tower is going to hire these
people next year.
You are.
Well,
yeah.
it's the heart like what's happening in
the campus is going to happen in society
in five years.
It's already,
it's already happened.
This is actually an important point.
Um,
I've,
I just gave a talk,
get a at a big law firm here in New York
where they're very devoted to diversity,
but they're doing it right.
They're really thinking about diversity.
Why is diversity good?
And say have a whole month on viewpoint
diversity,
which is just fantastic.
And what I'm learning from talking to a
number of people in the business world
is that in the last year they're now all
these pressures on leaders to endorse
this condemned that sign,
this open letter and through human
resources.
That's right.
But it's the same dynamic we have on
campus and the answer to it.
So if anybody,
anybody watching here,
if you run a business,
if you have friends who are in business,
I think the only,
the,
there are only two stable equilibria.
One is that every organization is just
either all right when we're all left
wing,
but that will be disastrous.
So either you just say,
okay,
we're on one side that we terrible.
The other is what we call the Chicago
principles of free expression.
The University of Chicago has the best
statement out there on how the
university provides a platform on which
multiple views can contest the
university does not take anyone's side.
That's the only other stable
alternative.
And I think leaders need to do this in
business.
It certainly universities.
So we're encouraging every university to
adopt the Chicago principles because a
lot of what mass action is,
is an attempt to compel the authority to
come in on your side and punish your
enemies.
Yep.
And so that has to stop.
We can go how,
how effectively is the Chicago statement
on,
on how effectively is the Chicago
statement being disseminated?
How rapidly our universities signing up
or,
or um,
there a few signed on early in this
whole crisis.
I'm a purdue,
they're about 10 or 15 that have,
that have endorsed it or something like
it.
Uh,
it's not enough to just endorse
something,
but if you have leadership that's
committed to creating an open platform
in which people can disagree.
Um,
and I,
and one sense very encouraging,
I've been invited by a number of
university presidents to come speak.
We have all kinds of,
of innovation to Heterodox Academy to
foster a more inclusive climate in which
people can actually engage with
difference.
There's a lot of interests.
So I think the university leaders were
very slow to react.
They didn't want to alienate certain
factions of students,
but they're almost all reasonable
people.
They're almost all liberal left.
I'm not illiberal.
They're horrified by what's going on.
They know they're sitting on top of a
powder.
They don't want things to blow up in
their face as happened at Evergreen.
So this brings us to our,
our,
another product,
the one that we're most excited by a.
So I just went online,
uh,
actually,
today,
uh,
it's called the open mind platform.
If you go to open mind platform.org,
you can find we've developed a,
an APP.
We have a whole library of readings and
videos who developed an APP that guides
you through.
We don't just say,
here's how engaged with different
viewpoints.
We start by saying why is it good and we
make the case that you need this.
Everybody needs this.
And to,
um,
we remind people that we're all
basically self righteous hypocrites.
We have quotes from wisdom traditions
around the world and we've all heard
this.
So just a little bit of a,
you know,
you can call it emotional manipulation
if you like,
but just get people into a mindset in
which they're willing to say,
oh yeah,
Whoa,
calm down.
We're all,
we're all a on to self righteous here.
And then we,
then we teach them some psychology about
motivated reasoning and only then do we
teach them to engage with views that are
not their own.
So we've already run this in about 15 to
20 classes.
Um,
the results so far look promising that
at the end of it,
the measures show that students are more
open to other ideas.
So the open my platform,
do you think is a tool that we think a
lot of universities are going to adopt
their.
There's a lot of interest in it.
If there's leadership,
if the professors generally do support
viewpoint diversity and open inquiry.
If we change freshmen orientation so
that students are trained first and
foremost in how to step back,
give people the benefit of the doubt,
be open minded.
If we do that first,
you know that's like behavioral exposure
to some degree,
right?
The idea would be that if you're,
if you're afraid or disgusted by
something that you don't understand the
appropriate treatment,
first of all,
the treatment is necessary because
otherwise you'll isolate yourself in the
ways that you already described and
second,
that brief exposure.
Voluntary exposure's going to be the
best curative.
That's the opposite of the safe space.
Id exactly need to be protected.
Safe space.
The safe space idea is the worst thing
you could possibly do for the very
people you're trying to.
Exactly.
Exactly mean to psychology,
what you know,
the psychology behind safe spaces and
microaggressions is just the exact
opposite of what we should be doing if
we want to create kids,
especially black kids,
gay kids,
we made whatever.
If you think that they are vulnerable to
more stigma,
more conflict if you think that they are
vulnerable,
that's especially when a safe space will
be temporarily pleasant,
but in the long run,
bad for.
Right.
And that's the critical issue too with
regards to safe spaces is that there are
sacrificing the medium and longterm of
the students' wellbeing,
let's say to the short term lack of fear
and conflict.
Their infant dialyzing them essentially.
So yeah.
Okay.
So.
Alright,
so I was thinking about discussion idea.
I've got a personality test online now
that's based on this big five aspect
scale,
but it might be interesting as something
for us to think about to do,
find people who are high in openness and
low in conscientiousness or orderliness
and offer them the opportunity to engage
in dialogue with people who have the
opposite personality traits.
No,
because,
well,
first of all,
because they're going to run into people
like that always,
right.
And,
and,
and maybe even establish a relationship
with them inadvertently.
And so being able to tolerate that might
give them the kind of insight that you
said you developed when you realized
that the conservative ethos was based on
a reasonable but not complete set of,
of,
of beneficial axiomatic presuppositions.
So.
Alright,
so now this is pretty much taken over
your life,
this heterodox academy as well as the
writing.
Now you're writing a couple of new
books.
I understand.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so since,
so I was in the psychology department at
the University of Virginia for a,
for 17 years and one of my book,
the righteous mind was coming out.
I wanted to move to New York City for a
year so I could do promotional work for
it and I just had,
my second child was just born and I knew
it would be hard to fly from
Charlottesville.
So I just happened to get a position,
temporary position here at Stern,
at the business school.
Um,
and when I first arrived I wasn't that
interested in business,
um,
but as soon as I got here,
occupy Wall Street happened and suddenly
it was like everyone's talking about
morality and politics and capitalism and
business.
And then I started learning about the
history of capitalism and I knew nothing
about it was fascinating and I started
seeing how free enterprise free markets
have helped raise,
wait,
raise living standards around the world.
Yes.
Poverty in a staggeringly rapid fashion
that's completely unprecedented threat,
especially since the year 2000.
That's right.
So since,
so,
you know,
here I was 48 years old discovering it,
nothing about it was like when I first
learned about evolution,
like wow,
this explains everything in the natural
world and learning about capitalism.
Business explained everything about the
built world and the world that we
actually live in.
Um,
and they were also all these business
scandals.
This was 2011 and the wake of the
financial crisis and I saw a huge
opening to begin applying moral
psychology to help corporations have
better ethics.
Um,
so I've been,
everything I do involves applying moral
psychology to help complex systems work
better,
so I've been focused on political
polarization and governance for years
before then and that led to the
righteous mind and then I got here to
Stern,
they offered me a job during that first
year and I took it and it's been
fantastic.
It's been really exciting.
It's like a whole new,
almost like being back in Grad school,
a whole bunch of new things to learn.
You must be a kind of a shock and
existential shock to be in a business
school in some sense.
No,
it's not,
it's not a shock.
I mean it's a different culture.
It's much more open in the sense that
it's so diverse like the things people
are doing,
there's not like a way that we do things
here and it's much more open to applied
projects to actually to applied
projects.
Yeah.
And so it was a perfect time for me.
Like I just,
you know,
the righteous mind that,
that wraps up like the first half of my
career,
like everything I did is in that book
and now it's time for something new and
that new thing was going to be I'm
looking at how morality or moral
psychology both underlines or,
or,
or is the foundation for our ability to
do capitalism like contracts,
reciprocity,
all sorts of things.
And how are left,
right?
Divide,
um,
from the righteous mind makes it hard
for us to figure out what's true.
Like if you're raised the minimum wage,
does that help or hurt the working poor?
Right.
If you're an economist on the left,
obviously helps them.
If you're on the right,
it obviously hurts them because fewer of
them have jobs and you can gerrymander
the measurement devices to reduce the
conclusions that you want,
which is a big problem.
That's right.
So I'm supposed to be writing a book
called three stories about capitalism,
the moral psychology of economic life.
And so I started traveling around the
world looking at how development is
going in various countries.
Uh,
I did a three month trip to Asia in
2015.
I came back from Asia,
my article came out with [inaudible] off
the colony,
American mind.
The bbs article was published,
uh,
and I thought,
okay,
now we can get back to this,
you know,
keep it in this capitalism book.
And then the university is kind of began
melting down in the fall and then we
started heterodox academy.
And so yes,
it has taken over my life.
It's,
it's basically a full time job in
addition to trying to write the.
I'm also working on,
so looking on it and I didn't want to
turn our article into a book because we
thought we'd said everything but men
have things been happening fast and
we've learned so much more since we
wrote that article and that article
when,
how long?
Well,
we wrote it in late 2014 and then we
edit it in early 2015 and it finally
came out in August of 2015.
Um,
and so in our last October,
Greg,
uh,
wrote to me and said,
John,
I think I do want to turn the article
into a book because we know so much more
now and it's,
the problem is so much more serious than
it was any evidence.
My God,
the evidence about mental,
the mental health crisis of adolescence
when Greg and I wrote the article,
we were,
you know,
we saw lots of hints that depression and
anxiety were going way up and we think
that's related to the,
the overprotection yeah,
part two.
Okay.
So let's,
let's talk about that just for a sec and
then go back to the book.
So I've got a potential demographic
explanation for that in part.
Well,
and I don't know if you guys have looked
into this or not.
Well,
there's,
there's two things that I think might be
contributing to it.
One is two or three things.
One is the average age at which children
are the average age at which people have
children has gone way up.
That's true.
Okay.
So why does that matter?
We're all because I think people get
more conservative and cautious as they
get older a little bit,
but that's true,
but it's a very small effect and it's,
wait a second,
it's the having of the kids,
which is what makes them more
conservative.
When you have kids,
you are more threat sensitive,
you're more likely to vote for the right
wing party.
So just delaying child,
child a childbirth wouldn't.
Okay.
What about,
what about fewer siblings?
That would.
Yes.
That's part of it.
Uh,
and this is what we're seeing in Asia
too,
when you have a lot of kids,
you're not quite as worried.
You don't have all your eggs in one
basket.
Well,
and you can't quite as worried and the
siblings raised each other.
That's right.
Right.
And then there's a lot of keystrokes
fight.
Exactly.
It's the free play and the fighting,
the working things out for themselves.
Those are essential skills of adulthood.
Okay.
So see,
so then.
Alright.
So smaller family sizes.
Part of it.
Agree.
Well,
and then also what's happening
increasingly in schools is that kids
aren't allowed free play and there are
certain not even allowed.
Rough and tumble free play,
which that's right.
That's one of the biggest things about.
So the two that there are three giant
there.
There are a lot of.
I mean this is such actually it's really
fun puzzle because it's like the biggest
social science puzzle of our age.
What is happening that's making so many
of our systems go haywire and I'm
focusing on the university.
The big three I would say are one is the
loss of,
of free,
of unsupervised freeplay.
Yeah.
And Peter Gray has been brilliant on
this.
He's a Boston college showing how even
among young animals they have to
practice the skills for adulthood.
Yeah.
And getting in,
showing that too.
Exactly.
So getting in conflicts and then dealing
with it and sometimes losing and you
come back having game in which there's a
problem but you have to work it out or
the game stars.
That's what kids always did.
It's only recently in the nine,
beginning in the nineties that it
they're always supervised because we're
afraid if we take our eyes off them
there'll be kidnapped and that was never
a risk was never a risk.
You know,
I've kind of wondered about this gender
flexibility issue as a form of delayed
fantasy play.
Good.
And let me go ahead.
Because it looks to me like that is,
you know,
when kids are little and three and four,
say three to seven,
they do a tremendous amount of identity
play,
you know,
they pretend they're animals,
they pretend they're their parents,
they,
they pretend they're girls.
If they're boys,
they pretend they're boys.
If they're girls like they really do a
tremendous amount of identity play.
And one of the things that's been really
puzzling me is,
well,
what happens if that isn't,
um,
if they never have an opportunity for
that because they're not engaging in
fantasy play,
maybe it's just delayed till adulthood.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So because plate,
it's almost impossible to overstate the
importance of that rough and tumble play
and then the fantasy play that enables
you to adopt different identities.
And then the negotiated games that you
talked about that enabled people to
handle both,
both victory,
but even more importantly,
last.
That's right.
So that's possible.
That could well be.
I know that I have no,
no opinion on,
but the big three factors that I think
are explaining,
explaining part of what's happening on
campus are one,
the loss of the unsupervised place so
that the kids have always,
there's always an adult present and so
they come to college and they expect
there to be an adult and dean somebody
if there's a conflict.
That's one.
Two is social media which hit just as
ign,
Internet generation.
This is Jean twinkies work,
you know,
we used to,
we used to think that I'm a,
we used to think that the millennial
generation ends in 1998 or 2000,
but gene 20 shows a looking at for large
data sets that birth year 1995 kids born
in 1995 and after are really different.
They're values are different.
They have much higher rates of anxiety
and depression,
especially the girls.
Boys have gone up,
grows,
gone way up.
Um,
and the reason seems to be that facebook
lowered its age.
Um,
uh,
so in 2005 you had to be a college
student at a certain number of colleges
to get facebook in 2006,
you can be any 11 year old who lies and
says that she's 13 and you've got a
facebook account,
um,
uh,
but then you're using on your parent's
pc,
it's in 2007.
The iphone comes out and it saturates
the market faster than any consumer
product ever has.
So by 2000,
10 or 11,
a lot of adolescents have have facebook
and other social platforms and this is
just devastating especially to girls
because it's not texting.
Texting is just me to you,
you know,
that's back and forth.
That's fine that,
you know,
we,
when we were kids,
you called your friends on the phone,
that's fine.
The problem seems to be according to
twinkie,
it's especially platforms in which he
puts something out and then you wait and
see what everyone says and that
especially as damaging to girls who
already are at risk of eating disorders
and image disorders.
So girls become more susceptible to
negative emotion when they hit puberty.
Well,
there,
yes,
yes.
That's always been the case.
Then there's another issue too with
regards to female aggression.
So no,
it's clearly the case that males are
more likely to be physically damaging
slash aggressive than females are.
But what females use his reputation
savaging.
That's right.
So that's Nikki.
Nikki crikey passed away a couple of
years ago showed that if you add it all
up,
boys and girls equally aggressive,
but the boys aggression is more
physical.
The girls,
the more relational.
So if you imagine a bunch of 13,
14 year olds in their middle schools and
then you parachute in a whole bunch of
iphones,
everybody's got one of their pots in it
before.
What are the boys going to do?
They're going to play video games and
that doesn't hurt anybody,
but the girls are going to use it to
amplify the social interactions.
So this is 20 twinkies explanation.
I think it makes a lot of sense.
So it's a,
it's a catastrophe.
It's a crisis and we're really hurting,
especially the girls.
Um,
so we've got to change something about
that anyway.
But social media is,
is possibly the largest single reason
why things are going haywire on campus.
The third big factor in,
and do you think it's primarily facebook
or can you tell?
Well,
it's,
it's uh,
uh,
the kids use a lot of different
platforms,
but from what I hear,
instagram,
facebook,
snapchat,
it.
Again,
the thing is it's one to many.
That's what's bad at anything if,
if it's,
you put something out there and you see
how many people like it,
that's what's right.
And there's always the threat that it'll
go viral in a terrible way.
So that's exactly the sort of damage
limit that's perfectly limited damage.
Unlimited downside to saying something.
So what do you do?
Careful.
Right?
So I don't know if I want to like that
post because you know,
I could get in big trouble for it.
Right?
Well the benefit to liking it as minimal
and the potential catastrophe for this
unless expected to like it,
in which case you'd better like it
because if you don't like it you'll get
in trouble.
So it's a much more of a mob mentality.
Kids are afraid,
you know,
I'm not blaming the kids,
I'm very sympathetic to them and these
are,
my kids are,
my kids are 11 and seven,
they're going to come up into this.
Um,
so the kids have been raised in a,
in a social environment,
it's much more about mob mob formation
and mob attacks and Bob defend defenses
against mobs.
Um,
and then,
so the third factor then is the
political polarization and that
purification or institutions.
So if you imagine coming up in the
nineties when political polarization is
going up,
we're beginning to hate each other more
across party lines,
but it's not that hard.
Not that,
that nasty,
but it's been getting much,
much more hostile so that now if
someone,
like,
if someone's a,
is,
if someone goes to a campus Republicans
meeting,
if it's a Democrat who goes to a meeting
of the campus,
Republicans has happened at UC Santa
Cruz a couple weeks ago,
um,
uh,
and someone finds out,
you know,
the.
So the,
the,
the hatred,
the cross-party hatred is so much
stronger now.
And many institutions are much pure.
So if you went to college in the
nineties,
there might've been a few conservative
professors around,
but now there aren't.
So as you said before,
it's like exposure therapy if you've
never encountered a conservative idea.
And then if conservative like Heather
Mcdonald comes to speak on your campus,
well this is like a major immune
response problem.
We've got to get the tribe together and
mob her and you know,
shut her down.
Um,
so those are the.
I mean there are many other reasons,
but the loss of unsupervised play,
social media and rice and polarization,
those are the three big ones,
right?
Well those are big problems,
especially the loss of unsupervised
play.
It's not,
it's not obvious at all how that might
be addressed.
Yes it is.
Okay,
good.
Good.
Everyone should,
just by Lenore skenazy,
his book,
free range kids and then they should
loosen up and give their kids more
unsupervised time.
Now you can't do this alone.
You'll be arrested.
I tried to get my son to go out across
the street to,
you know,
buy groceries when he was nine years
old.
And he'd say,
look,
but you know,
Daddy,
people look at me funny there,
there are other kids out there.
Um,
and so lenore has started a fantastic
organization called let grow.
So if you were to let grow.org,
okay,
we'll put all this in the description,
all of these things,
right?
So I'm on the board of it as an advisor.
Peter Gray,
uh,
expert on,
on play is on the board and they're
doing these simple things.
Simple,
simple things like you convinced the
school to just open up the playground an
hour early or keep it open after school.
Why should kids always have organized
activities and soccer practice?
Just give them a place to play where
there's a nurse available.
If someone gets hurt,
there is an adult but he's not
supervising.
He's just over there,
right?
So don't worry parents,
there is an adult but beyond that can do
what they want.
And they just started this a few weeks
ago and the results are fantastic.
The kids were having so much fun.
They are becoming more independent,
they're more willing to do projects on
their own.
It's working out great.
So,
oh,
that's really good,
do this on your own,
but the thing is we all know something's
wrong.
So those are very practical,
very practical piece of advice for,
for schools.
It's like open up the unsupervised play
facilities and,
and,
and facilitate their use.
That's right.
Give,
give everyone a place which is safe.
And by safe,
I mean physically safe,
right?
Never use the word safety to describe
emotions and ideas.
Safety means physical safety.
So you've got to provide a physically
safe place for the kids to play.
And beyond that you let them go.
Now there will arise.
Problems of bullying.
So if it's repeated harassment or you
know,
well,
I know a book about God,
which by down always called bullying,
what we know and what we can do about
it.
And it was written,
it's got to be 30 years ago and always
cut the real,
the,
uh,
the incidents of bullying in the
Scandinavian countries down by 50
percent.
And he really,
really targets what bullying means.
So he's not a safe space guy by any
stretch of the imagination.
Um,
I don't know what the origins of it are.
I know that evaluations of his program
in America show it anywhere from zero to
20 percent reductions in much smaller in
the u.
s in the U.
s yeah.
The question is whether or not they were
able to implement them with the rigor he
did in the U.
S.
yeah.
But bullying programs are part of the
problem because bullying clearly is a
problem.
We need to do something about it,
but because we have what's called
concept creep.
Yeah.
So,
so it's not a bad concept.
Creep looks like even.
Yeah,
that's right.
Uh,
so now it's the case that if,
if kids don't invite,
if some kids want to do something and
they don't invite another kid,
they've excluded that kid.
Right.
Well that could be bullied.
I've read of schools in Europe that
don't allow kids to have best friends
for exactly that reason.
Yeah.
Well,
because this is also something that
really bothers me about the misuse of
the iat because it's not that easy to
distinguish in group preference,
which no one can.
No one went in their right mind.
Would want to eliminate in group
preference,
given that it governs your choice of
mate and your behavior towards your
family members,
let's say,
to,
to distinguish that between outgroup
exclusion.
There's no,
no simple matter and to tell kids that
they can't have a best friend is another
thing that interferes with an important
part of their.
That's right.
Yeah.
I think both of us have spent a lot of
time looking at ancient wisdom at,
at the writings of,
of,
of people long ago.
Uh,
and I,
I often come back to aristotle's claim
that any virtue carried to extremes
becomes advice.
So inclusion is a good thing if people
are being excluded because they have a
physical stigma or,
or they're overweight or their skin
color.
So we need to be looking at the reasons
why kids are excluded.
But if you say inclusion is the primary
virtue,
inclusion over everything else.
And so if those two best friends are
excluding others,
know more best friend,
this is madness.
This is a vice.
So I think that again,
you know,
it's a virtue unless it's carried to
extremes.
Well,
that's probably a pretty good place to
stop,
I would say,
unless you.
Have,
you have anything else that you wanted
to talk about?
We were,
we talked about the role of religion and
in the fact that people are naturally
religious thinkers.
We talked about the Heterodox Academy.
We talked about your work on disgust and
your plans for the academy.
You talked about your books.
Is there anything else that that might
be of interest that you can think of?
Um,
just that,
uh,
I'll just say that I'm actually
optimistic about what's going to happen
on campus.
I think things might continue to get
worse this year.
Um,
but I think there's an interesting
phenomena called preference
falsification when you have people not
speaking honestly,
as you had under communism,
when you have a whole system where
almost everybody thinks this is
terrible.
I hate this,
but I don't dare say anything.
When you have preference,
falsification is to work by team or
Koran.
Um,
and everybody hears everybody else's
preferences.
So they think,
okay,
that's what everybody thinks.
When you have an unraveling,
it can unravel very quickly.
And that's what happened in the
communist countries because everybody
hated it and it felt amazingly quickly.
And I think the,
you know,
the,
the pushback at read last week or there
was written up last week.
So I think because most people,
and we're starting to see is that a lot
of people of color also is that,
you know,
you're not speaking for me.
I mean every group is diverse.
And so when you have a variety of people
and you have progressive speaking,
when you have a variety of people,
um,
I,
I think we're going to see more and more
people standing up saying,
wait,
what's happening is this is not right.
This is illiberal.
This is opposed to the values of the
academy.
This is not what I want for myself or my
kids or my students.
So I do think that we're going to start
seeing a lot more people standing up.
Um,
and one of our goals of heterodox
academy is to just help put out the
ideas that people need.
And this is what you're doing to just
put out the ideas,
critique the bad ideas,
and put out concepts in that that can
contest in this space of ideas and get
good information.
So if people go to Heterodoxacademy.org
on our research pages,
we have all the information that,
what all the polls say.
What's the current information about,
about students attitudes?
We have the history of this.
We have a lot of research on who is more
biased,
left or right.
Well,
turns out both sides are about equally
biased.
So we think that by just doing what we
actually do well as academics,
that is research making arguments,
being common,
civil,
um,
we actually think that we can turn this
around.
So if anybody watching this as a
professor,
I would invite you to join.
Go to Heterodoxacademy Dot Org,
uh,
and science.
Okay.
So,
so let me ask you one more question.
I mean,
I'm,
that,
that sounds good and I'm,
it's good to hear that you're
optimistic.
I mean,
I,
I waiver,
although I wouldn't say I'm pessimistic,
I,
I just think we're in one of those
situations where things could spiral in
either direction very rapidly and that
worries me.
What about the disciplines on campus
that seemed to be primarily devoted to
the activist cause?
Like because my view is,
or my fear is that we've subsidized the
activist disciplines,
let's say women's studies as a good
example,
but we could say social work and then
the faculties of education now as well.
I think they're in the same,
in the same bin.
Let's,
let's,
let's put it that way.
That women's studies programs in
particular,
their express goal expressed on their
websites is to produce social justice.
Radical left leaning activists.
And so like for awhile,
one of the things I proposed in Canada
was that the conservatives in particular
cut the university funding by 25 percent
so that the universities would have to
sort themselves out.
But then that was,
that was a provocative claim obviously.
But then I thought,
well that's not a good idea because it
opens up the door to political
interference in the academy and that's
bad.
That's left.
No,
that's right.
That's right.
But the academy has done a very bad job
of policing itself methodologically and
we have these disciplines.
Women's studies I think is a prime
example and that's been very much
criticized in Canada by Janice Flamenco
who used to be.
Yeah.
Yeah,
she is.
And she's,
she,
she's not an unnatural mill.
You when she's doing such things,
you know,
she's,
she's a brave and tough person and she's
gone after the women's studies types on
methodological grounds particularly.
But,
but there are people who are working
full time at doing nothing but producing
the kind of polar.
So what do you have any thoughts about?
Yes,
I do.
I think
so.
I'm here.
I teach in business school here and I
teach a course called professional
responsibility and I teach my students
about their fiduciary duties,
their duties to their employers,
the duties that we have to each other.
And fiduciary duty refers to a very,
very high standard of care.
If you're managing someone's money,
you know,
you,
you really have to be committed to doing
what's in their interest,
not in your interest.
And I think we need that concept in the
academy.
We have a mature project,
we call it fiduciary duties or just
professional duties,
but I think we have two primary
professional duties that we must never,
never be tray one,
the most important one in our role as
scholars is our duty to the truth.
We must never say things that we think
are false or allow people to stay,
things that we think are false because
we're afraid if we challenge them,
we'll get in trouble.
So we have a fiduciary duty to the truth
and political,
ideological commitments clearly warp us,
they make us do things,
they make us,
they push us.
Um,
so we've got a whole.
We've got to recognize that if we let
our systems get out of whack,
we are betraying the truth.
Were systemically,
or do you want to.
If we ever went systemic,
truth isn't problem.
We are systemically betraying the truth
in many of our disciplines.
So I think we need an awareness of that
and we need to hold ourselves to a
higher standard than in our role as
teachers.
We have an here,
we really can call it a fiduciary duty.
These are people's children who are sent
to us to educate,
to enlarge their minds,
to teach them skills.
If we were to use them for our sexual
pleasure,
it's obviously a horrific crime,
but what is it if we use them for
ideological purposes,
if we say you've given me your children
to educate,
I'm waging a political battle.
I'm going to try to get your statements,
tools,
ms.tools.
That is horrific.
That is unacceptable.
We are violating our duties.
So I think,
right.
But the response to that,
especially from the postmodernist types
is that that's all the ribs.
There's only ideologic yeah.
Perfect.
So back to your original question,
um,
are there problem departments?
Absolutely.
So I want it to put forth these two
commitments to truth and to educating
not indoctrinating and universities that
embrace these highest goals like the
University of Chicago I think is the
best candidate will probably find that
they need to do something about
department that don't live up to those
goals,
other universities.
And I think Brown is leading the way on
this one so far.
I mean the early in 2015,
the president had all kinds of
statements about brown is committed to
social justice,
a fundamental bedrock commitment to
social justice.
She said so if some universities choose
to devote themselves to social justice,
that's fine.
Just be up front about it.
Say So.
So students will know if you want social
justice training,
you go to Brown.
But if you want to actually be trained
to find the truth to do research,
you go to Chicago and I think we're
going to see people flooding to Chicago
and schools like it.
So what I'm hoping what I'm hoping.
So that's the mechanism there.
If they,
if they make,
if they make their statements public
that the choice of the students will be
to go to the universities that hold the
principles that you just described over
the other one.
So it'll be a marketplace choice.
Exactly.
That's right.
So that's why I said when I talked about
the emperor's new clothes,
we have a situation,
we have a gigantic market failure in
which our top universities are offering
a product that most consumers don't
want.
And so my prediction is that Chicago is
going to see a huge surge of
applications this year.
And if that's true,
um,
I think other universities are going,
they're going to take notice.
So I'm hoping that we'll see a schism in
the American academy between those
universities that stand up and say,
this is madness.
We are committed to providing a
platform.
We don't discriminate based on viewpoint
and politics.
That's the Chicago way.
And those that say no whereabouts social
justice come here and we will train you
to fight for social justice and against
the right.
So if,
if people have clear choices,
then I think we're gonna see a big
change.
And that's why I'm optimistic.
I think we're going to see that.
Alright,
well thank you very much.
It was great talking with you.